[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur tv 78 pour un
nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés votre
rendez vous hebdomadaire nous discutons
des sujets qui sont l'actualité un
numéro un peu particulier aujourd'hui
puisque nous sommes au salon autonomie
murrow qui parle de l'autonomie des
personnes en situation de handicap ou en
situation de dépendance suivez-moi
selon un baromètre d'opinion de la
direction de la recherche des études de
l'évaluation et des statistiques moins
d'un français sur cinq placerait sont
proches en perte d'autonomie dans une
institution spécialisée
3 / 500 docu prêt ou l'accueillerait
[Musique]
un salon in situ et en ligne c'est la
cinquième édition de hitomi françois
garez vous êtes le président d'une vie
l'association de favorise qui vise à
favoriser les échanges et le partage des
connaissances l'autonomie la dépendance
est un sujet toujours plus d'actualité
écoutez c'est un sujet on a lancé il ya
une vingtaine d'années et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui en 2021 et une savez une
préoccupation des dix ou vingt
prochaines années et d'ailleurs à midi
je déjeunais avec des représentants du
conseil départemental des yvelines et du
conseil départemental des hauts-de-seine
et on est tous unanimes pour dire ce
sera le vrai sujet de société les 20 ans
à venir à le numérique est déjà très
présent dans nos vip donc s'adresser aux
situations de dépendance et de
handicapés qu'ils veulent et le
numérique faut y faire très attention ça
peut être un très bel outil d'appui mais
c'est pas ce qui va gérer réellement
l'indépendance parce que la dépendance
ça va aussi bien de la santé ça va aussi
bien dans l'habitat ça va aussi bien que
dans les mobilités mais la question est
de savoir comment 24 heures sur 24 on
sera en contact permanent avec les
dépendants et c'est toute la question
aujourd'hui de la notion du maintien
domicile il faut garder de l'humain
aussi alors évidemment il est important
avoir de l'humain l'humain ça peut le
numérique peut servir par exemple la
téléphonie était d'à mais on ne peut pas
agir avec des gens dépendants sans qu'il
y ait tout un travail avec eux les
personnes présentes physiquement alors
selon une étude de l'insee d'ici 2050 le
nombre d'habitants âgés de 75 ans et
plus ou moins jeunes pourraient
atteindre 200 mille personnes
quels seront les problématiques c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui quand on aura à peu
près entre 7 et 15 % de la population et
qui aura plus de 75 ans il est évident
que c'est une révolution en termes d'âge
par rapport à ce qu'il se passait il ya
une quinzaine ou une vingtaine d'années
donc obligatoirement la société au
médiateur dans les organisations des
collectivités doivent s'adapter à cette
question là et justement comment font
ces échanges là là aujourd'hui déjà
avant c'était souvent des cld centre
d'action sociale qui étaient les bureaux
de bienfaisance aujourd'hui on a lancé
une agence du développement justement
volontairement et je crois que c'est
quelque chose qui va être pris en charge
complètement non ça évoluera aussi au
niveau de l'état sait on voit bien même
dans différents pays d'europe et chez
nous ça doit beaucoup évolué entre les
structures hospitalières non
hospitalière et bien évidemment aussi
toutes les structures l'aide à la
dépendance oui si vous parlez de nonne
hospitalier il ya parfois si de
l'inquiétude à placer un proche ou quand
on est âgé de partir de quitter son sont
à sa résidence souvent la solution de
facilité c'est de le placer dans une
maison de retraite dans un ehpad et
cetera et c'est vrai que le maintien à
domicile nécessite toute une
organisation avec éventuellement
quelqu'un qui va vous organiser vos
journées quelqu'un qui va vous faire
venir des prestataires dont vous avez
besoin que ce soit on est le ménage que
ce soit éventuellement pour la nuit que
ce soit aussi santé et donc tu es tout
une structure s'est déplacé
éventuellement les ehpad et les maisons
de retraite chez soi domicile et puis on
à la crise de lakovic qui continue
encore qui a effrayé certains est ce que
ça change et aussi les problématiques va
déjà ça fait évoluer un peu les
problématiques parce que le problème du
coc vide a obligé tout un ensemble de
personnes à rester chez elle quoi et
notamment beaucoup les plus dépendants
et donc ça nous a obligés à mettre des
systèmes d'appel du système de
ressources on n'avait pas prévu au
départ par rapport aux salons autonome
il ya un peu moins d'un an était lancé
hitano me booste c'est un programme
d'accélération douze projets ont été
intégrés
mettons aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui par rapport à cette tension
d'intégration c'est un terme important
intégration ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
il ya un bouquet de services et sait
comment ce bouquet de services on le met
en place pour les personnes dépendantes
et donc c'est évident c'est un une idée
à développer une idée aussi bien par le
net par internet mais une idée à
développer possible par rapport aux gens
qui s'occupent de la dépendance y en
avait 12 y en aura d'autres des projets
des projets il y en a des tas en temps
de paix mais le point important c'est
que tous ceux qui ont à gérer
éventuellement les plus de 65 ans ce
soit les caisses de retraite que ce soit
l' agence régionale de santé que ce soit
les familles que ce soit éventuellement
aussi ceux qui travaillent sur ce
secteur d'activité il est évident
qu'aujourd'hui il faudrait une
transversalité complet de telle façon à
ce qu'il y ait véritablement une
organisation rationnelle pour prendre en
charge le déploiement merci françois
garay merci le salon autonomie ce sont
des exposants qui présentent leurs
dernières innovations ils sont une
cinquantaine à être présent en
présentiel
[Musique]
plus d'un million trois cent mille
personnes sont en perte d'autonomie en
france et parmi certaines solutions il
peut y avoir aussi la domotique et à ma
smart jarvis bonjour à des vérins bozo
vous avez des solutions sur notamment la
domotique ce qu'elle peut apporter à ces
personnes tout à fait en fait on a
développé des solutions d'abord pour
monsieur et madame tout le monde et puis
à l'aide d'ituano midi on a développé on
a transposé toute cette technologie là
au service des seniors et les personnes
en situation d'handicap alors ça passe
par plusieurs dispositifs on a un
dispositif comme celui à qui un
dispositif de contrôle vocal un peu
comme google ou une amazone alexa mais
là tout est traité en local il n'y a pas
de fuite des données personnelles et à
la voix je vais pouvoir commander les
différentes lumières mon chauffage etc
on peut essayer si vous voulez jarvis
qu'est ce qui peut faire alors jarvis et
1 le salon
et voilà par an il est ici là il a
éteint la lumière du salon mais j'ai
également un écran tactile n'est que je
peux avoir aussi sur mon smartphone sur
une tablette comme vous pouvez avoir et
sur laquelle vous avez piloté également
l'ensemble
du logement donc là on appuyant dessus
je vais contrôler mes différentes
lumières mais je vais pouvoir aussi
lancé des scénarios comme celle du gard
qu'un scénario yoga et donc le gema
lampes qui passe en rose toutes les
autres lumières qui s'éteignent et la
musique qui se lance quand on parle
perte d'autonomie on pense souvent
seniors est ce que ce sont des petites
choses qui ne les inquiète pas non au
contraire aujourd'hui on est sur une
nouvelle génération de seniors aussi qui
a commencé à maîtriser le numérique dont
il n'y a aucun problème pour ça et puis
surtout c'est des choses sur lesquelles
on va travailler d'abord en concertation
avec les seniors et personnes en
situation d'handicap ensuite en
expérimentation et ça notamment
justement grâce à nos programmes
d'économie boost qui nous a permis
justement d'accéder à des seniors donc
qu'ils sont chez eux au maintien à
domicile mais aussi à des ehpad où on a
pu expérimenter nos systèmes remonter
les problèmes les bugs et puis ensuite
les corriger ce soit vraiment adaptée
quand on parle de perte d'autonomie il
n'y a pas que les seniors vous l'avez
dit via les personnes en situation de
handicap et vous avez aussi un
appartement c'est ça on y va vous suivez
alors là nous sommes dans un appartement
plus pour les personnes en situation de
handicap la différence avec le précédent
alors la première différence qui est
quand même flagrante c'est la superficie
on est dans un appartement qui est plus
grand il ya plus d espace les portes
sont plus larges et notamment par
exemple dans la salle de bain on voit
très bien qu'un fauteuil roulant peut
facilement se tourne et pivoté sur
lui-même dans ces pièces là donc ça
c'est vraiment le truc le plus
significatif on voit d'autres choses par
exemple on a un écran qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure dans l'espace seniors mais ici
les plus bas outre qu'il n'y à 45 degrés
voilà quelques petites adaptations mais
concrètement quand même il ya beaucoup
de similitudes entre les deux
appartements alors massmart jarvis vous
êtes booster depuis un an quand vous en
êtes déjà arrivé à ce boost alors bon
non une société muriaux ti dont on a été
créée là d'ailleurs on est basé ici sur
le campus donc on va vraiment une
proximité est en lien très fort avec une
vie autonome y est donc assez
naturellement on est parti dans ce
programme en ayant suivi tout un tas de
démarches notamment une sélection etc
mais on a pu être accompagnée avec
avec i te nomine boost et pour nous
c'était vraiment un accélérateur un vrai
tremplin pour la mise en sur le marché
de notre solution de services access a
été comment ça a été un accompagnement
administratif financier
alors je dirais d'abord il ya une partie
de formation parce que en fait nous on
est des techno c'est à dire que l'on
s'est fabriqué à inventer tout un tas de
choses mais maintenant on veut aussi il
faut que ça réponde en fait à la demande
en face est donc là il vit a pu nous
accompagner nous aider sur ce format là
on a eu des formations aussi sur le
pitch la prise de parole tout un tas de
deux sujets comme ça je pense notamment
à une formation qu'on a eue avec ait un
pacte qui était vraiment sur comment est
ce qu'on explique ce qu on fait quoi
finalement ensuite il ya toute la partie
je dirais expérimentation ça c'est aussi
quelque chose qui est important je
parlais tout à l'heure c'est comment
aujourd'hui on va installer chez des
personnes dans des ehpad nos dispositifs
et remonter les informations pour sortir
un produit qui soit vraiment qu'ils
répondent vraiment aux besoins et aux
usages en fait de nos utilisateurs
donc je pense que c'est vraiment
important et c'est à fait unique en
france d'avoir un accompagnement en
accélérateur de ce type là qui est pas
juste un accélérateur comme vous dites
justement financiers il ya tout ce qui
va autour
aujourd'hui la problématique de rester
chez soi est très forte est ce que on
est devant la solution l'une des
solutions pour faciliter ce maintien à
domicile alors ici
d'abord si on parle des appartements il
ya plusieurs solutions l'idée c'est que
ce soit des appartements qu'ils soient
vivants qui vont perdurer aussi dans le
temps ils seront pas démonté tout de
suite après le salon est donc il peut
aussi y avoir différents acteurs qui
vont mettre leurs produits les faire
évoluer et puis mon résultat alors on a
des choses de très techniques
technologiques comme ce que j'ai pu vous
montrer par rapport avec smart jarvis
mais on a aussi des trucs beaucoup plus
simple notamment là on a une bouteille
d'eau avec un porte bouteilles d'eau etc
donc il peut y avoir aussi des choses
très simples parfois mais qui facilite
grandement la vie par rapport à la
maille smart jarvis je dirais pas qu'on
est la solution miracle mais on est
effectivement aussi l'une des solutions
pour permettre le maintien à domicile le
plus longtemps possible n'ayant en
appartement une maison qu'ils soient
simples à utiliser tous les jours quel
est le futur justement de la domotique
et du maintien à domicile aurait sur ce
qu'on travaille c'est notamment grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle a pas gérer
l'urgence mais justement à détecter
avant d'arriver dans l'urgence notamment
d'un détecteur qui a lu une prise qui va
permettre la nuit d'allumer un petit
éclairage et d'éviter la chute bon ça
c'est des choses qui existent déjà par
contre notre détecteur en plus va
compter le nombre de fois que la
personne se lève la nuit alors on sait
que d'habitude elle se lève 2 à 3 fois
et puis depuis quelques temps elle se
lève 5 6 7 fois par nuit donc on détecte
qui est un début de problème peut être
un début de pathologies dont va alerter
les proches l'auxiliaire de vie qui vont
ensuite pouvoir humainement traiter le
problème
merci beaucoup je vous en prie vous
merci
améliorer certains états de santé grâce
à l'interaction et nos trois mères est
une société basée à andrésy elle est
spécialisée dans les technologies
destinées à cette amélioration de la
qualité de vie des personnes atteintes
de troubles du comportement et de la
communication
on est beaucoup plus sur
l'accompagnement le confort de soins et
le confort aussi au travail des
professionnels de santé on a des
solutions qui facilitent leur travail au
quotidien qui améliore aussi la
perception donc des établissements
auprès donc des professionnels mais
aussi des résidentes parole et dans un
peu plus de 400 établissements en france
maintenant zohra on est un peu plus de
30 établissements et oreilles on est sur
un développement qui démarre on a vu un
projet avec le 78 où ils ont testé notre
solution dans quelques établissements
[Musique]
quand on parle de situation de perte
d'autonomie ou de handicap on pense très
souvent aux aidants qu'ils soient
parents enfants ou proches il y a aussi
les accompagnants professionnels 830
mille équivalents temps plein sont
employés auprès de personnes âgées en
perte d'autonomie
ils peuvent être du monde médical ou
travailleurs sociaux
ça nous donne des idées ça permet de
créer des partenariats de d'identifier
les acteurs qui peuvent nous aider à
déployer des projets au service des
personnes âgées
et aussi de se faire connaître déjà voir
tout ce qui est une innovation technique
nous notre champ d'application c'est des
patients qui vont avoir souvent
handicaps neurologiques importants pour
essayer rose en plaques les accidents
vasculaires cérébrales et paraplégie ou
tétraplégie
donc dans ce cadre là l'évolution de la
médecine et est quand même assez modeste
quand les seniors restent à la maison et
qu'ils sont
rien n'est adapté en fait c'est là où
tout prendre la place le lève malade
tout ça c'est vrai que c'est encombrant
matériel et là c'est vrai qu'il ya des
structures pendant plus lit qui m'ont
tous seuls déjà ça c'est un c'est
quelque chose en moins déjà qui prend
moins de place on va dire
c'est la fin de ce statut de société
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
moment des changes sur tv 78 et d'ici là
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]